COMEDIANS?
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS THAT AND MORE
IN SEEN AND UNSEEN.
BUT FIRST, AMERICA AND SHUT
DOWN, DAY 30, IF YOU CAN BELIEVE
IT.
THE AMERICAN DEATH TOLL
SURPASSES 30,000 PEOPLE TONIGHT,
BUT EVEN WITH THAT STAGGERING
NUMBER AND ALL THE LOSS OF LIFE
THAT COMES ALONG WITH IT, THERE
WAS SOME GOOD NEWS TODAY.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE HEADED
ABSOLUTELY IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS YOU HAVE
EVERY STATE THAT IS EITHER DOING
BETTER OR ON THE WAY TO DOING
BETTER.
>> OVER THE LAST 5-6 DAYS WE’VE
SEEN DECLINES IN CASES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND THIS HAS BEEN
VERY REASSURING FOR US.
>> IN TERMS OF OUR CASES AND
NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS, THAT
ARE BEING UTILIZED, THEY ARE ALL
TRENDING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE FLATTENED THE
CURVE.
>> THE CHANGE OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS, DOWN.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
ICU ADMISSIONS IS DOWN, THAT’S
GOOD NEWS.
INTIMATIONS ARE DOWN, THAT’S
VERY GOOD NEWS.
>> Laura: I JUST SMILE.
WE NEEDED THIS GOOD NEWS.
THE ORIGINAL MODELS WERE VERY
WRONG AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SOCIAL DISTANCING AND OTHER
THINGS ARE HAPPENING AS WELL.
WE GET INTO THAT LATER IN THE
WEEK, BUT AMAZING, LOOK AT THIS
NEW YORK CHART ON DAILY
HOSPITALIZATION, IT WAS UP
BEHIND CUOMO DURING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THAT’S A BEAUTIFUL THING, LOOK
AT WHERE IT’S GOING AND THAT IS
AFTER SUCH A BRUTAL SIX WEEKS IN
THE CITY.
REMEMBER, IT WAS JUST THREE
WEEKS AGO THAT THE ANGLE WAS
BASICALLY ALONE AND STRONGLY
QUESTIONING THE MODELS THAT HAD
PREDICTED A TSUNAMI FOR NEW YORK
HOSPITALS.
REMEMBER GOVERNOR CUOMO’S CLAIM
THAT HE WOULD NEED NEARLY
30000-40,000 VENTILATORS IN THE
STATE.
WELL, TODAY, THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID.
>> WE HAVE STABILIZED OUR
HEALTH CARE SITUATIONS.
NEW YORK HAD ONE OF THE EARLIER
CURVES.
THERE ARE OTHER PLACES IN THIS
COUNTRY BUT ARE NOW SEEING
INCREASES IN THE DEATH RATE IN
THIS -- THEY ARE SEEING STRESS
ON THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
WE WILL SEND 100 VENTILATORS TO
MICHIGAN AND 52 THE STATE OF
MARYLAND.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GIVING AWAY
THE VENTILATORS, THAT’S HOW
COMPARATIVELY WELL THEY’RE DOING
WHEN IT COMES TO CRITICAL CARE
IN NEW YORK.
AND THIS IS WHERE THINGS STAND
IN CALIFORNIA.
REMEMBER THE STATE OF 40 MILLION
PEOPLE.
IT REPORTED 76 CORONAVIRUS
DEATHS SO FAR TODAY FOR A TOTAL
OF 864 DEATHS.
BY AUGUST 4TH, IF THE NEWEST
PROJECTIONS ARE ACCURATE, THE
MORTALITY RATE THERE WILL BE
ASTRONOMICALLY LOW.
GOSH, WHAT’S GOING ON IN
CALIFORNIA?
WHY IS IT HAPPENING THAT WAY?
THEY CLOSE DOWN ON, WHAT,
MARCH 15TH, 17TH, CANNOT REALLY
EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS?
A STUDY IN THE ECONOMIST THAT
MANY MORE AMERICANS WITH MILD OR
NO SYMPTOMS WERE UNDOUBTEDLY
INFECTED WITH COVID-19 BUT NEVER
TESTED.
THAT’S THAT THE NOMINATOR WE’VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
IF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WERE
INFECTED WEEKS AGO WITHOUT DYING
DYING, THE VIRUS MUST BE LESS
DEADLY THAN OFFICIAL DATA
SUGGESTS.
COVID-19 TAKES 20-25 DAYS TO
KILL VICTIMS.
THE PAPER RECKONS THAT 7 MILLION
AMERICANS WERE INFECTED FROM
MARCH 8TH 2 THE 14TH.
AND SOCIAL DATA SHOWS THAT 7,000
DEATHS THREE WEEKS LATER.
THE RESULTING FATALITY RATE IS
.1%.
SIMILAR TO THAT OF THE FLU.
THAT’S AMAZINGLY LOW.
JUST A TENTH OF SOME OTHER
ESTIMATES.
BY COMPARISON, LOOK AT WHERE
COVID WINDS UP IN MORTALITY AS
COMPARED TO THE FLU.
OKAY, THERE IT IS.
A FASCINATING, GIVEN WHAT OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS HAD PREDICTED
AGAIN JUST 21 DAYS AGO.
AND OF COURSE EMINENT SCIENTISTS
WHO ARE INFORMING THEM.
NOW, DESPITE ALL THE GOOD NEWS,
THERE’S NO SIGN THAT LIBERAL
GOVERNORS OR MAYORS ARE CHANGING
THEIR DARK THEIR TROPONIN
RESPONSES.
IN FACT, SOME MAY EVEN BE
RAMPING THEM UP.
L.A. MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI STILL
SAYS NO BIG GATHERINGS.
>> UNTIL THERE IS EITHER A
VACCINE, SOME SORT OF
PHARMACEUTICAL INTERVENTION OR
HERD IMMUNITY, SCIENCE IS THE
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR.
GOT MANY, MANY MILES TO WALK
BEFORE WE’RE GOING TO BE BACK IN
THOSE ENVIRONMENTS.
>> Laura: A FEW WEEKS AGO HE
WAS WARNING THAT L.A. COUNTY WAS
GOING TO BE LIKE NEW YORK CITY.
WELL, WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
THANKFULLY THAT DIDN’T COME TO
PASS.
IF THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA --
IF THEY’RE NOT HAPPY WITH THESE
DECISIONS AT SOME POINT, THEY’RE
GOING TO NEED TO MAKE THEIR
VOICES HEARD.
THEY’RE GOING TO NEED TO SPEAK
UP IN ANY WAY THAT THEY CAN.
THESE ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS,
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
REPRESENTING THE HEALTH OF THE
WHOLE STATE AND MAKING SURE
PEOPLE ARE BEHAVING RESPONSIBLY
FOR SURE.
LIKE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS --
WELL, DID THIS YESTERDAY IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND TODAY IN
MICHIGAN WHERE THOUSANDS OF
PATRIOTS RALLIED FOR REOPENING.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK TO AN
ORGANIZER IN A MOMENT.
TODAY I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS
DESPERATE NEED TO REOPEN
AMERICA.
YOU SEE IT, YOU FEEL IT, PEOPLE
ARE GETTING ANTSY, BUT NOT JUST
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO OUT TO A
RESTAURANT, BECAUSE THEY SENSE
WHAT’S REALLY HAPPENING.
AND THEN THE ONGOING VIOLATIONS
OF OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES AND THE
SHUTDOWN, WE’VE BEEN DOCUMENTING
THEM.
I RAN ACROSS A RECENT
"VANITY FAIR" INTERVIEW WITH
ANTHONY FAUCI.
AND THE QUESTION TO HIM, BELIEVE
IT OR NOT, WAS ABOUT WHETHER
IT’S SAFE DURING THE CRISIS FOR
PEOPLE TO USE THE HOOK UP APPS
LIKE TINDER AND GRINDER.
WELL, HE ANSWER THE QUESTION AND
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
YOU KNOW, THAT’S TOUGH BECAUSE
IT’S WHAT’S CALLED RELATIVE
RISK.
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR OWN
TOLERANCE FOR RISK.
YOU COULD FIGURE OUT IF YOU WANT
TO MEET SOMEBODY IF YOU’RE
LOOKING FOR A FRIEND, SIT IN A
ROOM AND PUT A MASK ON AND CHAT
A BIT.
IF YOU WANT TO GO A LITTLE BIT
MORE INTIMATE, WELL THEN, THAT’S
YOUR CHOICE REGARDING A RISK.
BINGO!
OKAY.
LIFE IS FILLED WITH RISKS IN
OTHER WORDS.
WE SHOULD ALL BE CAREFUL AND WE
SHOULD ALL BE RESPONSIBLE, BUT
THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT, NOR
REALLY SHOULD TRY ELIMINATE ALL
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH COVID-19
ANYMORE THAN IT COULD WITH THE
H1N1 OR THE SWINE FLU.
WHEN WE STEP OUT OF THE DOOR,
WHEN WE WALK ONTO THE STREETS,
WE ENTER A BUILDING, WE GET INTO
A CAR, GET ON A BIKE, THERE ARE
ALWAYS RELATIVE RISKS.
BUT THE DAMAGE TO MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF LIVES, INCLUDING
CHILDREN’S’ LIVES AND OUR BASIC
FREEDOMS DURING THE SHUTDOWN,
THAT’S ALSO VERY REAL AND FOR
MANY IT HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING.
MANY ARE WILLING TO TAKE THE
RISK OF CONTRACTING THE VIRUS.
IT WOULD SEEM THAT IN THE POLE
AND, WHAT THEY RATE IS MORE
WORRISOME TO THEM.
AND THEY WOULD RISK THIS IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE THEIR WAY OF
LIFE.
>> THERE’S ALSO DEATH INVOLVED
IN KEEPING IT CLOSED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MENTAL HEALTH,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SUICIDES,
SUICIDE HOTLINES, WHICH ARE
EXPLODING, PEOPLE THAT DIDN’T
TAKE DRUGS AND NOW THEY’RE
BECOMING DRUG ADDICTED BECAUSE
THEY’RE GOING THROUGH A PROBLEM,
THEY HAVE NO JOB, THEY HAVE NO
MONEY COMING IN.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
>> Laura: FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ALL OF AMERICA IS THE PATIENT
AND IF WE DON’T REOPEN SOON, SHE
IS TO FLATLINE.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE